eight o'clock in the morning in
Liberia's capital Monrovia Jonathan doma
is a guest on the live show radio Maria
he reports about the latest incidents of
corruption in the education system the
28 year old works for the Center for
transparency and accountability in
Liberia today he speaks about corruption
and schools about teachers putting money
intended for books into their own
pockets the radio show is an important
platform for the activists it is
important because the public depends on
us a lot there's a ladder is expected of
our work by the public so we always try
our best to share the resolve our works
our families our research the finest of
our research to the public tell us about
some of those things that there's a lot
of interest in the show every day more
and more people talk about corruption in
government institutions and in politics
despite some initial progress liberia
recently fell in the world's corruption
perception index we are the common
people benefit from the resources that
it's going to her for all the reasons
that I country are you cannot see it to
cop the corrosion corrosion is very very
serious problem in our country parasia
to stand at their every part of lagrua
has been affected by corrosion the
public sector and the private Jonathan
doma and his colleagues at center would
be fighting a losing battle were it not
for their dedicated volunteers their
problem when they cover a case of
corruption it doesn't mean that the
offender will be punished the activists
aren't giving up though in fact they're
starting to see results here at the
University of Liberia students are
staging a protest against rising tuition
rates they're upset about a lack of
transparency Jonathan will meet with the
University Council to clarify some
important points
what will be done with the money that is
expected to come from the students what
improvements we are sped to see for
example the institution likes a
functional library they don't have
computer labs they are talking about
internet on campuses none of them are
actually happening here right now after
a week long standoff success the
president of the country rules for the
status quo to be maintained there will
be no raise of tuition fees for now more
importantly though it's a good sign for
Liberia says Jonathan doma that more and
more young people are stepping up to ask
difficult questions
you